why are you the way that you are
well I like I said when my parents got
divorced Michael they fought for custody
of our family dog Primo more than me so
I was actually raised by a German
Shepherd more than I was by a two-parent
home so I come from the BLM Playbook of
the broken home and just like Saul
alinsky's Rules for Radicals the same
Playbook that Barack Obama and all these
freaks use on the left I'm using it on
the conservative movement I'm basically
using the rules for radical and using
the projection and just projecting all
of their crazy lunacy like the fact that
Leah Thomas swam on the men's team for
three years and then was able to take
some sort of medicine some you know
hormone therapy and was able to compete
against the women and become a national
champion in multiple events so it's
ludicrous it's absurd but that's where
we live in a world where the Supreme
Court Justice cantaji Brown Jackson
can't even Define what a woman is and I
know that is a Hot Topic in the daily
wire Community for the daily wire fans